[Music]
there are too many dead to cope with
right now in parts of the indian capital
and they're piled up in vehicles outside
the coronavirus rules mean this is where
most relatives have to say goodbye
it's massively distressing and hugely
undignified
they're working all hours inside they
just
can't stop and it's been like this for
the last two weeks
all day and all night
the bodies just keep on coming whilst we
were there bodies were being brought in
every few minutes there's no room left
inside the crematorium
so they've spilled out into the open
ground next door
coronavares has ripped through this city
and they're rushing to keep up with the
devastation it's caused
and this ancient hindu ritual is now
both a desperately lonely affair
but also crowded out alongside dozens of
other hasty funerals
[Applause]
india is still hitting world record
coronavirus figures
with one covert death in just under
every
four minutes in delhi and its health
care system
is buckling
[Music]
so those with sick relatives are doing
everything they can to keep them alive
queuing up to fill up their own oxygen
cylinders
these are like gold dust in this city
with a black market value of four times
their normal price
if this would happen like last year then
it would have been okay nobody knew
about it
but they got a year and they wasted it
completely on election rallies and all
the other stuff
so it's heartbreaking but we don't have
any other options
some of these people have been lining up
for hours but they are getting access to
oxygen
and they're asking if they can get hold
of it how come the government
and the hospitals can't
a sports stadium opened only days ago as
a covered facility because of the
shortage of beds in the city
was turning away patients today
but you've only got 50 people in there i
understand
it's the same story across much of the
capital with several of the top
hospitals still reporting an acute
shortage of oxygen
and the prime minister calling top level
meetings to try to solve the crisis
why aren't you admitting any people why
have you got no
oxygen beds available
that didn't stop hina from begging them
to admit her father
he's a rickshaw driver and suffering
he's also the only earner in his family
and they've spent three months wages
buying an oxygen tank from an illegal
market
so he can breathe rich or poor
indians are doing whatever they can to
keep breathing
every section of society has been hit
with the deaths rising at their fastest
rate since the start of the pandemic
and cutting across every creed and
religion
but there's doubt about almost
everything with warnings that the surge
in testing
is now leading to a lack of testing
material
is burying his brother but with a death
certificate he doesn't believe
20 members my family
no kovit no positivity
and as a covert victim that means the
precious muslim rituals
are also banned and their heartache is
all the more
because of what feels like gross
insensitivity
and a keen sense that all this could
have been avoided
the country i am feeling very bad i have
money i have everything but i can't save
my sister
because no bed nothing nothing like that
no gas
no oxygen no bed where we can do where
we can go
all across the city and across the
country coronavirus is leaving its scars
on the land and on its people
and india is now the global center of
this pandemic
just as it's waning in many other
countries
alex crawford sky news new delhi